like you know you joined the idol group
were you like I guess ever interested or
had an interest in like the idol culture
of Japan before you decided to join I
always loved watching Idols you know
like
and like just the hello project groups
and stuff I I loved them but it was like
really never a career option I didn't
even think I could be one you know so
right I didn't think I could be once it
was never a career option so yeah what
do you think the appeal of being an idol
is
being an idol and it's
because I'm just trying to imagine
because obviously to our audience is
very Western and I think that uh a lot
of people's struggles really understand
the appeal of Idols in like kind of a
western like perspective and like we
don't really get it even though they
very much have their own version of it
in terms of the way that they do it in
Japan I think a lot of people they don't
really get it yeah I think when most
people in the west hear the word Idol
they think of like Japan or Korea yeah
you know or like some kind of Asian
country whereas like you know not to say
that like you know we had [__] people
we definitely have it it's just it's
like a different it's a different it's a
different Beast entirely even the K-pop
and J-pop that like I feel like it's so
different oh yes yeah absolutely
very very different yeah and K-pop is
more like when you debut like you need
to be perfect but in J-pop it's more
like they want people yeah they want
people that's not well established and
like they want
Yeah the more you look like a potato
yeah so that's why like a lot of people
say when you go into auditions you
should never dye your hair because like
it should you know be natural
because they just like want to see you
go from like a normal girl to like they
want to see you in the purest form right
are they like dumb with you after you've
crushed it they're like I'm done I'm
gonna find someone else I hope not
but yeah that's nice okay like I'm
curious because you know especially in
like Idol culture I guess
marketability comes into a lot of plays
uh especially with the Japanese idol
culture did you were you ever like
not like were you ever kind of like not
pressured but were you ever like kind of
like given like kind of like a niche or
a character to fulfill as your like
public stage
um well I mean the they didn't really
tell me to be like you know actively
cute and stuff like that but I mean they
would tell me to not cuss of course
you know they're like you know watch
your language and those kind of things
but um I feel like our group isn't
really as uh strict as strict you know
it's not like act like a certain way but
that's very like that's what you and a
lot of like Western media we get told a
lot of time from a journalist whatever
it's so tough It's so strict you know
you have to do this you have to do an X
and it always seems like that but I mean
that's great to hear yeah
like rather than him producing you it's
more because there's so many girls yeah
it's like
how you can produce yourself you know it
makes sense she's like I'm not saying
careful
it's literally like we gave you the
chance you know like we gave you the
stage yeah so whoever can like Blossom
on their own like I mean that makes way
more sense than being like you should be
this character this weekend yeah so that
was actually one of the reasons why I
started Twitter as well right right our
group um we weren't gonna have any
social media at first
but I was like don't you mean X actually
so yeah because like I was I was doing a
little bit of research on you and I saw
that like you know now you have quite
actually you know not only a large fan
base in Japan but also in a lot of
English-speaking countries well
obviously because now everyone knows you
can speak English
um and I heard that one of the big
reasons why you got a big English fan
base is because you were memeing a
little bit on Twitter yeah you're you're
a little meme star on Twitter I really
um respected
you literally looked up to the biggest
memes
so you know I just wanted people I
didn't want to use like social media as
like advertisement I wanted it to be
something that would brighten somebody's
day you know like I wanted it to yeah so
which turned out to be an amazing
decision
uh because I think I discovered you
through either your Twitter or your
YouTube
um because there weren't like you know
back back when you first became an idol
there weren't a lot of
I don't know if there are like any other
Idols that uh spoke English in a
Japanese idol group so kind of like you
I think for you you just bridge the gap
especially for Western audience to like
kind of like make it more approachable
um not to mention you had that like
almost personality Gap as well of like
you know in none of them you had you
know you were the idol girl right you
know playing you know playing the role
in the group and then meanwhile over on
Twitter you're like memes you know and I
think just like that almost like
disparity between the two personalities
was just like oh that's actually kind of
dope but like she can be an idol girl
but also be a memester
yeah I feel I feel that's how it worked
out but like how did you like I guess
you know when you decided to start the
Twitter like and you started to like you
know post memes and you know just be you
like how did the that reception I guess
like come about well
um like I said you know a lot of idol
groups from akimoto-san it's how you
produce yourself and when the first
single came out I was in the very third
lane of the
um new single and it was like it was
pretty obvious I was not the favorite
the groups and so I but um there's
Politics on the song yeah I mean like it
would have been fine if it was just me
you know because it's like you know like
more people not seeing me the better but
it was my character too like if I was in
the third line that means my character
was also in the very back and I didn't
want that like I wanted her to shine so
I took dancing lessons and
um so you know to get better at dancing
and then go to the front line and then
also I was like how should I get more
fans and I knew I didn't I couldn't
really make a lot of friends in person
but I had a lot of friends online like
in America so I was like you know what
I'm probably better on internet so you
know so I was like um I don't think I
can get a lot of fans during the live so
can I just like have my own like
internet section yeah
so yeah that was one of the reasons why
I started I was like you know I can't
really show my personality in person
because I get so nervous but online it's
like total different yeah yeah it's like
it's easier to talk and everything so
right you said that you like kind of
mentioned you know don't cost or
anything like that yeah how much Freedom
do you get with like the online stuff
and the online content that you do
um for Twitter it's literally you can
post anything you want I mean unless you
know it's like really poetic yeah yeah
yeah stuff but for my YouTube videos
most idle politics yeah
but for my YouTube videos
um I have to show my like staff members
first yeah that was one of the reasons
why um my YouTube video right now my
subtitles have nothing to do with what
I'm saying
hi everyone my subtitles would be like
today's the worst day of my life
on purpose wait do you put the subtitles
oh my God why do you do that you're such
a villain I love it I just really like
dark humor you know and it's just like
self-deprecating jokes is how I cope
with my life
but when I do it in Japanese like my
manager stops me like my whole entire
management team stops me being like stop
that's so get your brain that you can
keep the Western audience like amused of
what they love yeah yeah so the only way
I can the only way I can like go past
them is if I write it in English right
because like how are they gonna check it
how are you gonna know what I'm saying
you are like absolutely like limit
testing like the idols like industry
it's like five heads right that's so
cute
I want to start doing that but with
Japanese sometimes just being like hey
guys we're here right now doing this
video in Japanese
that's such a good idea yeah hell yeah
you do this for your for your tweets as
well yeah for my twos as well always so
you so you tweet out both in Japanese
and English yeah so for the Japanese
part they're like
Emoji the English bite would be like why
did I wake up today
like the nightmare starts after I wake
up
they do but then when they they're like
why are you treating this I'm like
that's a mistranslation
you know like why are you believing like
it's hard in English
the joke's really hard to say in
Japanese like don't believe that holy
[__] you're like the hero of the
industry dude like you're just like
subverting everyone's expectations
that's crazy that's so funny okay now
that I'm hearing that I can totally see
why you know all the English speakers
are like this chick's life yeah if
oceanoko had this story I'd be way more
interested
[Music]
this is so interesting yeah this is so
fascinating every single like chance
you've had to like push it or not yeah
I'll try it yeah that's good have you
seen you know
[Music]
do you feel like it's uh how accurate
um I mean the part where like the very
first episode you know where the
producer is like oh because they're a
big like you know from this group like I
don't even know who they are I kind of
relate to that you know I feel like a
lot of people are like oh like welcome
welcome because of like the big agency
yeah yeah so and I kind of feel that as
well so I relate to it and I got scared